Super Mario maker is like a 2d
platforming gift that keeps on giving
and fans can expect even more in the
latest update the free update coming
next week will add an assortment of new
items to give players even more ways to
create their very own Super Mario stages
one of the items is a fire Koopa clown
car which flies around the level and
shoots fireballs it can fire charged
shots that are powerful enough to break
blocks another new item coming in the
free update is the P warp door which
unlike standard p doors are only visible
while a piece which is activated the
update will also add a doughnut-shaped
item called a bumper as its name
suggests this item sends Mario bouncing
when he touches it in addition to the
new items Super Mario makers update will
include new leaderboard functionality
that shows the fastest clear time for a
given level this information will be
displayed under a new menu tab
appropriately called World Records Super
Mario makers director yosuke oceano
passed along some comments regarding the
new update and items players have
already created and shared a huge number
of courses and we've been listening to
all of the feedback about how people
have been playing them we hope that by
adding in new items will see even more
interesting courses than ever before in
case you needed an excuse it sounds like
a good time to jump back in and design
more levels for more on Super Mario
maker and all things gaming you're
already in the right place